un ancien Premier ministre à la tête de
la RATP officiel un 5 mois après son
départ de Matignon Jean Castex a été
choisi par Emmanuel Macron pour devenir
le nouveau président directeur général
du groupe et les succès à la Catherine
Gilloise une nomination clé à un an de
la Coupe du monde de rugby et 2 ans des
Jeux Olympiques Paris 2024 Jean Castex
nommé à la RATP il y avait la photo de
jean-castrophe dans le métro donc je
sais pas si on peut revoir cette photo
si elle est disponible mais elle est
tellement étonnante et vous voyez
comment une photo marque parfois une
opinion publique cette photo il y a pas
besoin de parler vous voyez il y a tout
dans cette photo ça fait des semaines
qu'on voit plusieurs photos parce
qu'effectivement il y en a plusieurs de
photos de gens cassés dans le métro qui
circule on se dit enfin un politique
proche des gens on était les premiers à
s'en réjouir sur ce plateau et là on
découvre qu'en fait on nous a
complètement dupé tout ça c'était le
mascarade c'était un énorme coup de com
depuis le début donc ça envoie encore un
signal que les politiques nous
manipulent et nous prennent pour des
conséquences
[Musique]
ni d'espion
France
vous travaillez pour les renseignements
généraux ou parce que ça a l'air d'être
commun chez vous hein
au titre de ce même article 54 si
je vous remercie
dernier mon mystère j'aimerais bien
maintenant que vous en trouviez une du
quotidien
qui a trouvé le moyen de transport
ultime à Blois bienvenue à Blois 1400
ans avant Jésus-Christ ma gueule
le chacal du rodé avec son âme il veut
rien savoir il vit dans son temps mon
propre un autre foutoir nous guette et
on parle pénurie mais il y avait
longtemps cette fois de riz une pénurie
de riz donc une pénue
c'est une pénue il faut que les gens
arrêtent mangent réduisent leur
consommation de viande on n'a pas dit
dimanche
c'est ce que tu répètes je n'ai jamais
dit de ne plus manger de viande j'ai dit
de la réduire très sensiblement c'est
pas la même chose
je rétablis la vérité comme ça
sensiblement
assure je
il conteste revendique et proteste
insurgé exactement je rappelle on le
voit aussi avec les grèves nous sommes
un peuple de révolutionnaire nous avons
coupé la tête du roi c'est ancré en nous
c'est ancré dans nos mœurs dans notre
identité dans notre inconscience
collective le français par définition
aime se plaindre le français par
définition m critiquer tu peux dire en
haut qu'on a théâtre
quand j'entends la sonnerie je suis un
peu dégoûtée parce que j'avais prévu de
faire mes cheveux j'avais prévu de faire
plein de trucs si je vous emmène à Los
Angeles dans un appartement entièrement
fait en cake voilà toutes les pièces
sont des pâtisseries géantes en gâteau
oui si vous voulez mais comme c'était
Los Angeles je l'ai dit un petit peu à
l'anglaise les visiteurs arpente un
décor coloré et bien crémeux et pourtant
heureusement c'est du faux même si ça
paraît vrai sinon il y aurait quelques
problèmes d'invasion de fourmis ou autre
c'est sûr que là ça donne pas envie ça
fait peur c'est dégueulasse
[Rires]
ouais là vous allez loin
[Musique]
[Rires]
on me dit que vous trempez les biscuits
dans le soda alors je suis en éternel
enfant mais qu'est-ce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle je fais trempette donc à chaque
fois que je prends un biscuit j'ai la
manie de tremper dans un verre d'eau
dans un soda dans le café à chaque fois
votre biscuit dans un verre
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais bien aimé être musclé fort la
chanson que vous sifflez sur votre
douche
Jean te laisse était un 69 ans fidèle à
l'épitoche qu'il s'était choisi
un mec plutôt sympa un mec sympa et l'un
des auteurs préférés des Français